en el vídeo pasado usamos la serie mac
loring para aproximar coseno de x y lo
hicimos así usando este polinomio que
tenía un patrón sumamente interesante
veamos si este mismo patrón se repite
cuando aproximamos seno de x con una
serie de mac loring insistimos que una
serie de mclaren es en realidad una
serie de taylor cuando centramos nuestra
aproximación alrededor de x igual a 0 es
un caso especial de serie de taylor así
es que tomemos nuestra función
fx igual a seno de x f x igual a seno de
x llegamos lo mismo que hicimos con
coseno de x tomemos rápidamente las
derivadas de coseno de x así tenemos que
la primera derivada de seno de x es x
y la segunda derivada del seno de x es
la derivada de coseno x que es menos
seno de x la tercera derivada en la
derivada de menos 0 de x será efe pondré
3 entre paréntesis como la tercera
derivada en lugar de este tri prima y en
la deriva de menos seno de x que es
menos coseno de x la cuarta derivada la
cuarta derivada de f con respecto a x es
derivar me conozco seno de x que es seno
de x y como podemos ver al igual que con
coseno dx tenemos ciclos al calcular las
derivadas y para calcular la serie
mclovin tenemos que evaluar
fx y sus derivadas en x igual a cero
hagamos eso
así es que dejarme hacerlo en otro color
no el mismo azul que está usando voy a
usar ahora el púrpura loops no se ve
déjanos otro color
así es que efe de cero es seno de cero
que es igual a cero
efe primer cero efe primer cero es
coseno de cero coseno de cero es igual a
uno
efe mi prima de cero es menos seno de
cero menos seno de cero
es igual a cero efe
three prima la tercera derivada en cero
es igual a menos coseno de 0,901 así es
que esto es menos 1
efe 4 y prima o la cuarta derivada en 0
es igual a seno de 0 que es de nueva
cuenta 0 y así podríamos seguir pero
vemos este platón 0 10 menos 101 de
nuevo y así seguiría encontremos
entonces la representación polinomiales
'no la serie más gloria recordemos que
esta de aquí es la aproximación de
coseno de x y te vas acercando cada vez
más cada vez más sacó seno de x no va a
demostrar aquí que es exactamente coseno
de x pero a medida que tú agregas
términos esta expansión te acercas a
coseno de x de tal manera que agregando
un número infinito de términos este
polinomio es exactamente igual a coseno
de x hagamos ahora seno de x para otro
color este verde estar bueno pd xy ésta
hace una aproximación a seno de x a
medida que agreguemos más términos esto
va a ser una mejor aproximación
entonces hagamos la aproximación en el
primer término que se fue de 0 f de cero
que es igual a cero este término lo
vamos a incluir el siguiente término sf
prima de 0
efe primer ser es uno por equis este
término sería x + f
mi prima de 0 la segunda derivada en
células un deriva del 0 es cero tampoco
lo incluimos el tercer término que es la
derivada evaluada en cero este sería la
tercera derivada es menos 1 entonces
tendríamos aquí menos uno menos uno que
multiplica a
- uno que multiplica a uno entre tres
factorial por equis cúbica entonces
sería menos x cúbica sobre tres
factorial y el siguiente término que va
a ser cero
la cuarta deriva de evaluada en cero
vemos aquí que la cuarta y vera de valor
en cero es cero el coeficiente de este
término es cero lo que hace que este
término no aparezca en la serie y lo que
vemos aquí quizás no tenemos suficientes
términos para que veamos que está
sucediendo déjame hacer un término más
aquí abajo
entonces la quinta derivada de f la
quinta de ciudad de f con respecto a x
es co seno de x la quinta derivada
déjame hacerlo con el mismo color que
hemos utilizando la quinta derivada
evaluada en cero es igual coseno de cero
que es igual a 1
así es que el siguiente término nos
quedamos en la cuarta derivada evaluada
en cero que era cero siguiente terminó
es la quinta derivada que es 1 x
uno no lo escribimos siguiendo el patrón
que tenemos arriba sería x a la quinta
sobre 5 factorial y aquí hay algo
interesante para coseno de x tenemos
como primer término uno por equis a la
cero que es 1 y no tenemos x a la
potencia 1 de hecho no tenemos esa
potencia impar sólo tenemos x a la
potencia par dividido entre el factorial
de la potencia y los signos que se van
alternando y aquí tenemos x a la 0 yo no
diría que ese de su número par bueno
quizás he visto de alguna manera pero no
voy a entrar hoy en eso lo que tenemos
entonces el patrón x a la 0 x al
cuadrado a la cuarta ixe la sexta a la
octava x al número pares para la función
se en el patrón es similar sólo que
tenemos aquí potencias impares el primer
término es x a la 1 sobre 1 factorial
menos x a la 3 sobre 3 factorial más x a
la quinta sobre 5 factorial viéndolo
bien 0 si es número par
que decir mi mente está ahorita
divagando y así podemos seguir el
siguiente término siguiendo este patrón
sería menos x a la séptima sobre 7
factorial
x a la novena sobre 9 factorial ya que
hay algo interesante acerca de la
naturaleza de seno de xy coseno de x
como si estuvieran mutuamente llenando
el hueco que dejan entre sí tenemos que
coseno de x es x a la potencia par
dividido entre el factorial de esa
potencia cuando toma la representación
polinomio al del seno de xx a la
potencia impar dividido entre el
factorial de esa potencia con los signos
que se intercambian en el siguiente
vídeo haré a la x si lo que es
fascinante es que a la x parece una
combinación de seno de xy coseno de x
aunque en realidad no es tal
esta combinación se logra de hecho
cuando involucras números imaginarios y
es cuando empieza de verdad de verdad a
ser tan interesante que te dispara la
mente